ty frère aussi c'est pareil alors il
file alors je sais pas si vous regardiez
x-files x-files t'arriver mon frère
c'est bon c'était une heure et demie tu
croyais que tu allais voir un fantôme
qui voyait rien tu entends des justes eu
[Musique]
toute la série mon frère et tu crois et
tu flippes et un tt chez toi tu es comme
ça t'as jamais rien vu la map est arrivé
à un stylo et c'est un big tueurs non
mais sans déconner oui sauraient ils
sont et franchement ils ont tenu dix
saisons avec tous non mais ces détails
les mecs j'ai jamais un truc qui nous
faisait peur il y avait du sud 9 la sq
ali houhou mulder je sais plus qui était
qui et donc qui cherchait et pendant une
heure et demie on sait pas ce qu'ils
cherchent
et donc ils ont raison mais ils ont vécu
dix ans c'est juste un truc qui monte
dans la voiture il
[Musique]
partout où il va il mena une baguette de
pain qu avec en quoi est ce toujours qui
savait se faire attaquer il son papa
taquet pendant dix ans il ya rien eu
s'est rien passé et on regardait comme
des cours alors passé tout ce film à
faire le scénario elle madeleine bien à
elle a reçu le scénario là de manon des
sources elle a vu le fais mes frères
c'est la saison où c'est interdit de
[Musique]
séjour illégal et dans la colline et
paix et à l'autre je me rappelle hugo là
était un homme malin je t'aime mal donc
arabesques donc c'est une map jessica
fletcher larry là et puis donc qu'est ce
qu'ils font dans arabesque y met un mec
voilà et il le tue donc là le mec il est
mort boka qui c'est qui arrive c'est pas
le commissaire ont un truc ses
arabesques sais je suis tapé sur taris
wet esquisse effacé bimetu bas et tout
tu t'es quoi tout est romancé ouais mais
j'me mail web alors comment ça se fait
qu'il est mort tous un vrai bon jeu mais
j'me mêle j'me mêle et en fait ce qui se
passe j'ai remarqué dans par l'épisode
d'arabesques c'est que elle fait tout
l'enquète voilà ils sont comme ça parce
qu'elle est l'intrus
c'est comme hercule poirot elle est
réunie tous ceux dans une pièce comme ça
elle sait voilà alors madame smith
je vous ai vu vous étiez à 14h au tennis
donc impossible que vous soyez à 16
heures avec un couteau en train de
planter dans monsieur jones doit donc là
la rivalité toi 17h tu étais au bowling
donc c'est pas toi voilà les plats
prennent tellement bas c'est toi c'est
mister banzaï
mr banzaï c'est le cas tu es un mister
jones et là elle fait tout l'anc est
hélas ils sont tranquilles ce mr doute
et aille à mr goolsbee
il sort du placard en fait ils plongent
lors des x défaut meurtre et elle elle
trouve le gars qui aurait tué le mec qui
ont l'habitude mais sans les défauts
sanguins pendant une heure et demie
comme ça j'ai reçu un bon jour cette
série mais elle est passée qu'elle
romancière espèces de faunes assez alors
bassins laure mais racontée à ceux qui
nous regardent qu'il connaissait pas
manimal en animal sans cliquer là c'est
un mec déjà il avait tout et je loue le
mec déjà le héros déjà il a une tête me
home mes caprices des hurons dire un
fromage avec tu as déjà il a un peu une
tête est déjà celle où tu vois alors
donc il arrive et donc le mec il a un
don ils ont trouvé que ça c'est que le
mec il fait comme ça je me rappelle il
est comme ça et que c'est doit regarder
jouer et il mettait ses doigts comme ça
comme ça ils émettaient comme ça c'est
long il est comme ça et pouvait se
transformer en n'importe quel animal
mais lui le gars est pas et se
transformer en des animaux de ouf c'est
à dire le m
ce concentré de bout ce coma c'est tout
tu croyais qu'il allait transformer en
pot ter au départ le galilée kamal est
là le gars et se transforme en caux
débris mon frère c'était juste pour
aller écouter une chambre début la
découpe des ses parents comme par les
avancées des trucs de ouf dit va se
transformer mon frère à sa est un ours
polaire rouge gorge
c'est un peu nos séries ça m'a demandé
shérif fais moi peur tonnerre mais
caennais il ya eu aussi hulk à chaque
fois je dédie une contraire c'est un
gars il est tranquille ce après david
banner le gala man bon il marche et
tranquille il fait sa vie et détient un
mec il est vrai qu'ici tu arrives il est
comme les gentils quoi il en voiture ils
d'antioxydants arim pourquoi tu passes
pas quoi pourquoi je passe bas il est
toujours ce qui est pas parce que c'est
pas une priorité
ouais tu baves a dit pas ce bouffon et
là tu lis des bouffons l'alma king et là
le mec il se transforme en verve et il a
un pantalon c'est le clan gars quand je
m'énerve sont- ils se transforment en
bermuda c'est la première et les
scénaristes sont plus coupées pour mon
frère
saluant le gars il commet les ont poussé
les troquets l'origine quand il se
mêlèrent il se retrouve en bermuda
continuer comme cela est le cas il
arrive et donc il est comme ça il en
chemise mon frère yves ce type alors lui
explique on lui refusa en prêt-à-porter
faire à chaque fois qu'il s'est énervé
ça lui coûte henson à bali et lui à la
fois il est aimé des repas ça va encore
je vais devoir encore passer chez zara
là tu me fais chier dans métro non mais
trial et bd foutons qui pétait abymes
avec la gauche c'est colombo quand il
arrive sur la scène du crime
lui il a des meurtriers y tue la
personne mais il reste tranquille à côté
du gars tranquille ça lui donne bien où
l'on sait que je veux dire c'est pas moi
si les tuer puis le gard c'est le seul
mec il bien que tu es un gars mais il
reste quand même dans les paras soit il
est tranquille
le premier mec qui croît sur la scène du
crime colombo c'est le gas salut tu as
bien hélas s'il va pas lâcher le mec ça
veut dire le mec il va pas le lâcher
pendant une heure et demie c'est à dire
l'amour nous les pilotes durent une
heure et demie mais colombo le lâche pas
pendant un mois ça veut dire qu'ils sont
chez lui ni il lui a même des gâteaux le
mec à la fin même si c'est pas lui qui a
tué le gars il entend tellement plus
duguid m'a dit c'est quoi c'est moi
vas-y tu m'a saoulé masi mémoire prison
la base et sans décoller la ran il a été
mon nom mais je te jure et ça je vous
mets au défi
moi j'essaie de regarder c'est à dire tu
regardes le début tu vois le meurtre et
à la fin d'un temps juste hoffman en
lots
la règle est accompli était là quand tu
te réveilles tu as compris que colombo
il avait reconstitué ce que tu avais vu
les deux premières nuits